also new tonight here at 11 o'clock this  is a pretty unique situation not  something you see every day a woman in  the West Valley is offering space in her  own home to people who are stranded she  says to just show her your Council  flight and your new travel plans and  she's willing to help if she can  I felt compelled to because these people  are stranded here I got a floor that  they can lay on or a couch they can lay  on that you know they could come mess  their head here and take a shower and  get out of you know that mess down there  at the airport  she's got a big heart now if you match  the criteria and you're interested in  reaching out to Charlene we do have  information on how to get in touch with  her on our website at 8newsnow.com